a bombshell new report says a suspected
chinese spy
targeted california politicians axios
reporting that fong
even wound up in romantic or sexual
relationships
with two midwest mayors it is a story
straight out of a spy novel
alleging steaminess in skullduggery but
the biggest fish she targeted according
to axios
california congressman eric swalwell a
democrat on the house intelligence
committee so you're china
just like how people are competitive
nations are also very competitive
with china taking the crown and their
eyes are set on the west
and in this competition of nation states
in this struggle for power
intel and influence are the names of the
game intel is the name of the game dee
it's all about the intelligence if you
can know what your opponent is going to
do next if you can steer your opponent
in the direction you want them to go in
you basically control the future the
throne is as good as yours without ever
firing a bullet
so the question becomes how do we get
said intel and influence
there are many ways but here's the
problem the most powerful people in the
nations you're trying to topple
are usually going to be the strongest
supporters of the regime you're trying
to subvert
they're gonna be loyal hard to crack
hard to spy on they're gonna have far
too much to lose for them to betray
their country
i'm a loyal patriot i'm on my way to
getting promoted elected
why would i ever screw things up become
a trader or open myself up to prison
time
so if the logical side of their brain
won't let them betray their country
we need to attack this problem from a
more emotional dirtier angle
if you catch my drift and what is the
achilles heel of every man rich or poor
powerful
or weak what is the one thing that man
can't resist
man's insatiable desire for women
i'll just leave it at that wink wink yes
if we can use women to get powerful
politicians under their spell
we can get the intel we need in the form
of pillow talk gossip having easy access
to their phone and laptop
and we'll be able to get the influence
we need maybe you should do this honey
hey babe what do you think about voting
on this we'll call these spies swallows
or ravens for their male counterparts
beautiful charismatic female spies
putting an exciting twist on the world's
oldest profession
so who are these swallows how do they
work who do they target what tactics do
they use
all those juicy details are waiting for
you in this video
but first a segue to bluehost one of the
best rated web hosting platforms out
there that allows entrepreneurs artists
and bloggers to take their website from
startup to success
pick from hundreds of free and premium
themes get some of the fastest low times
and up times in the industry to help you
rank higher in google and have the power
to customize all the advanced features
you might need that other services don't
allow you to do
all in one beginner-friendly platform
and if you ever run into trouble their
legendary tech support is available via
phone or live chat 24 7.
with their one-click wordpress install
you can get up and running with your own
wordpress site in no time
get started with bluehost right now for
only 395 a month and receive a free
website domain and ssl for a year
by going to jake.yt bluehost with the
link in the video description
again that's jake.yt bluehost with the
link below
the us-china relationship in many ways
is significantly more complex
than the u.s soviet or u.s russian
relationship
the west has grown weak drunk on
shopping and social media torn about
by hatred between the races and as a
result
the world is in chaos
a great man once said power is a lot
like real estate it's all about location
location location closer you are to the
source
the higher your property value so common
sense would dictate that we should use
our swallows to target the biggest most
powerful politicians right away
but like we mentioned earlier the ones
at the top are harder to access they're
already super suspicious of everyone
around them
which makes our job that much harder and
on top of that we don't need
immediate results immediate
gratification like the west is addicted
to
no we're in this for the long run so a
better strategy a more
long-term strategy is to get our foot in
the door before the politician gets big
and powerful
after all today's mayors and city
council members are tomorrow's governors
congressmen
senators so we gotta sink our tiffin
while they're young
up and coming naive idealistic that's
when they're most vulnerable
take christine fong for example a
suspected chinese swallow
she was targeting local politicians
who were up and coming who were gonna be
stars and maybe make it to the national
level
one of her biggest targets was eric
swawwell a politician that rose to
prominence as one of the youngest
members of congress
that was eventually assigned a seat on
the subcommittee for cia oversight
within the committee on intelligence
a very information influenced rich
person to have in the bedroom
but it wasn't always like that christine
fang bagged him while eric was just a
puny city council member in california
this story is an example of how deeply
china is willing to go within local
politics to try and understand
and collect on and potentially influence
u.s politics
potential targets could also be aids
staffers and interns
those that are close to the source of
power that are more vulnerable and naive
so now that we know who our target
audience is we can now figure out who we
have to be in order to bed the target
[Music]
now obviously our swallow has to be very
very attractive
or else what's the point another deal
breaker is that they have to be
naturally charismatic
we've all met those people in our lives
they make you smile feel comfortable
they light up the room when they walk in
they're the life of the party and are
just really likable people with an
attractive personality
that is very hard to fix so they have to
be charismatic but there's more than
just looks and charisma that make an
effective swallow
if our target are up and coming
politicians they're going to be
ambitious half standards
and they'll want to surround themselves
with higher status people that can help
them in their climb to power
that's why the best most ideal swallows
are educated they attended the top
universities and of course speak perfect
english
how do you find these ideal women well
there are a lot of true believers in the
chinese communist cause
there are also a lot of ambitious
self-interested people that want to
climb the ranks of the chinese communist
cause
the tricky part is that you gotta find
the motivated women that are also
attractive that are also charismatic
that are also able to operate under
pressure behind what they perceive to be
enemy lines
and you gotta find them when they're
young and send them to american schools
to assimilate them
and if you found the perfect candidate
but they don't want to do this line of
work
well that's the beauty of being an
authoritarian regime
you have lots of leverage over your
servants so now that we have our ideal
targets and our ideal swallows
it's time for these two lovers to meet
[Music]
back in the soviet union days the kgb
would have to put in a lot of effort
into planning out coincidences
where a foreign leader would magically
run into a beautiful blonde russian
women at an event or bar
one operation involved over 100 highly
trained agents all coordinated to entrap
one target
it took a lot of manpower logistics
coordination but today
it's a lot simpler everyone including
those in power are just one click away
on social media
this is where again up and coming
politicians have an advantage
they're more likely to see your message
on twitter or instagram and respond
and don't worry if that doesn't work
america is a buffet of campaign rallies
political events fundraisers community
get-togethers business forums
where you can meet your ideal target and
strike up a relationship
then it's time for the arts of seduction
every human being is a puzzle of need
learn how to be the missing piece and
they will give you everything
let's face it human history has mostly
been ruled by men
men of violence brute strength but there
are some notable exceptions
with the greatest being cleopatra of
ancient egypt
these women couldn't gain power through
sheer violence and brute strength alone
like the boys did
so how did they do it by inventing and
mastering the art of seduction
they learn how to best manipulate man's
greatest weakness to their advantage
so that's what we have to do here the
first step is to identify what their
deepest desire
is maybe it's power maybe it's dominance
maybe they
want someone to take care of and nurture
maybe they want someone to dominate them
no judgments here everything afterwards
in the seduction process
all depends on this get it right and
they'll be hypnotized by you
and it will be child's play to mislead
and seduce them
then in general you'll want to draw the
man in with an alluring appearance
show them a few glimpses of the flesh
tease their imagination basically you
want to look like a goddess come to life
the goal is to not just make the man
want the dirty act
but you want to tease them with a rare
opportunity to possess
a fantasy figure once you have them
under your spell
make their fantasies come true you want
to nurture their dependence on you and
they'll instantly fall in love
then right when they're in the deepest
possible state of love when they're
completely
drunk on love pull back turn a cold
shoulder to them cease communication
neglect them emotionally
this will confuse the hell out of them
what did i do wrong everything was going
so well i gave her everything she wanted
remember these powerful ambitious men
are used to getting what they want
so when you make them go through
withdrawal for you when you hold back
when you play hard to get
they will come chasing trying to win
back the fantasy they once had
growing weak emotional and desperate in
the process
and boom this powerful man with the
intelligent influence you need
is now your slave figuratively speaking
which means they are right for
extraction
[Music]
in the soviet union days a lot of the
time when they entrap the victim
they simply reveal the trick and
blackmail them right away
if you don't work with us we'll expose
the affair you had and ruin your
marriage career get you fired voted out
of office
but remember we're in this for the long
run it's much better for you to stay in
the relationship with them without them
ever even knowing
you can keep gathering intel on their
habits preferences schedules friends
work
you know the scheduler has money
problems
the chief of staff has a drinking
problem these are important data points
you can use your influence over them to
sway their country on important china
related issues
after all how could you support a
measure that will hurt china if your
significant other is chinese
hoping to gain people's trust so that
she could perhaps in the future
help them change their mind on china
policy
and again power is like real estate you
gotta stay close to the source
now in a perfect world this is how it
will play out but if things don't work
out between you and your significant
other
you can use more desperate measures see
traders in the west hardly ever betray
their country because yes
i definitely believe in chinese
re-education camps
no most of the time it's not about
ideology it's about
money or having fun in the bedroom so if
things don't work out you can always
brag them with money
fundraising favors and so on
[Music]
after the story of the chinese swallow
christine fong was released recently
former cia officials said that there
could be thousands of these chinese
agents in america
now are intelligence officials usually
trustworthy
no not one bit on top of that mi5 in the
uk
also sound the alarm shortly after the
story broke they said it's almost a
certainty that china has swallows
operating in the uk
in 2011 france also warned that china
was using beautiful female spies to
steal their state secrets
and let's be honest the us and other
countries probably have their own
swallows
and u.s officials have admitted to using
such dirty tactics in the past
there's an old joke that most westerners
who have spent any time in soviet russia
have their own tale of how a kgb swallow
tried to seduce them
apparently swallows and ravens were a
very common thing in the kgb's playbook
but for the most part it was confined
within the soviet union
so that begs the question if china is
already bigger and more powerful than
the soviets ever were
and it's already been exposed that they
might have swallows operating all over
the west
how deep does this hidden network of
beautiful spies go
time will tell but what i do know is
that you should check out freshbooks
freshbooks is a small business
accounting software that lets you be
more productive
organized and get you paid faster you
can effortlessly log and organize all
your expenses so you're always ready for
tax season
you can accept credit cards to get you
paid up to 11 days faster you can wow
your clients with professional looking
invoices that only take seconds to
create
and you can even see when they've opened
your invoice and left you unread
and on top of that you can do all of
this no matter where you're at thanks to
their android and ios apps
so if you're a freelancer self-employed
or a small business owner
you can try out freshbooks for free for
30 days by going to jake.yt
freshbooks just enter jaketrain in the
how'd you hear about us section
that's jake.yt freshbooks with the link
below
so when this story broke a few weeks ago
i asked you guys on instagram if you
guys wanted to see a video on this
and it was total sarcasm i had like no
intention of making a video about this
but then like an overwhelming majority
of people responded to that story
like more than any other video idea poll
thing i've ever done
so here we are so if you want to
participate in future videos like this
and get a behind-the-scenes look on
stuff follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io because we have a ton of
fun over there now again
videos like this are a little bit even
more controversial we're really stepping
up the insanity for the end of 2020
so if you want more of them and to
support this channel financially so we
can make more of these videos
check out the brands that we talked
about earlier in the video with the
links in the video description
on the topic of being the end of 2020 it
has been an insane year
not just for the world but for the
channel in general uh
insane growth it's been insane and i
can't thank you guys enough like
seriously each and every one of you guys
that watches
likes leaves a comment i see the ones
out there that like repeatedly comment
on all my videos do you guys mean the
world to me
and have made all this possible so thank
you so much i know it's like a super
cheesy thing for youtubers to say but i
truly mean it
lots and lots of cool stuff planned out
for 2021
so be sure to stick around because it's
gonna be fun if this is your first time
on this channel my name is jake
obviously and we make video essays like
this on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business
economics power money crime all the
above
every single week for free so you should
definitely subscribe and turn on the
notification
bell and join the email notification
squad with the link in the video
description
that is going to wrap it up cheers to
the end of 2020 which a lot of people
complain that is the worst year ever but
there has been plenty
of worst years in history so i think
it's important for us to keep things in
perspective but here is the 2021 thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake stay dangerous
out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
so